foreign
[Music]
I found some code that caused me
physical pain
s out the guy who made the mess was me a
whole new Legacy
like
me
I'm living in a legacy land
you know Google itself is actually
turning 25 years old this year so we've
been through our share of growing pains
as well so far you've heard a bunch of
exciting announcements here at next you
might be asking all right how do these
help me out in Legacy land and we're
going to show you how some of the latest
Google Cloud features you might have
heard about so far at next can help you
do that too but we're going to need some
help so we invited some very special
people to help us out some of our Google
Cloud Champion innovators over the next
few minutes four of these amazing
Champion innovators are going to help
Richard and me take you on a whirlwind
tour of four big areas where new
features from Google Cloud can help us
build our next Legacy but first up to
help us reimagine what building apps
looks like in a generative AI world we
have Champion innovator and workspace
gde Alice Keeler
automate everything and if necessary use
code so I'm interested in Duet AI but
particularly duet AI in app sheet like
how can I automate with just those tools
yeah so how about uh incident reporting
so let's say for example that I'm a
school resource officer right or maybe
even the shift supervisor on a factory
floor I might want a consistent way for
anybody to report safety incidents or
maybe just near misses so let me see if
I can get that into a prompt that duet I
can use so I need to capture incident
reports each incident has Type status
description the date and each incident
should be assigned to what a team member
right and then all we have to do is
Click create app here we go we've
actually got an app yay what we just
shipped a web and mobile app and we
mostly use natural language right to
describe it so as a developer this is
really getting my wheels turning right
like how much farther can I go before I
have to start writing code yeah good
question like ideally I shouldn't even
have to type the incident report that is
a great use for another cool thing we
just shipped which is unstructured audio
capture with duet AI this is a minor
security incident that happened
yesterday
so we went from idea to app in some
number of seconds we added these rich
user experiences with audio capture and
chat but there's one more big feature
Alice that you said you wanted to add
there is and that's the ability to
actually take a picture of our
workstation here and see if the AI can
figure out if it's in or out of
compliance so let's say that I built an
amazing vertex AI Vision model to help
identify pictures of workstations that
are out of compliance actually let's not
say that let's show it I actually have
that app available right now it's built
out in a different Google Cloud project
it's behind an apogee API and it looks a
little something like this and now if
you pop open this card here okay it's
going to take a second for vertex AI to
read this picture oh here we got this a
man and a woman are posing for a picture
in front of a screen that says
broadcasting on it that's not too bad I
love this because everything from the
cloud function backwards can be owned by
me the developer and my team but this
gives me the option to let some of those
business teams put together their own
dashboards and reports and so on and
lets me Focus focus on where I can
provide unique value that's exactly
right so in just a few minutes what did
we do we shipped a web and mobile
application prototype using natural
language prompts we built an audio
capture with duet Ai and we called out
to other apis and machine learning
services on Google Cloud
how do you build a platform where team
product teams can develop fast the short
answer is a combination of vertical and
horizontal ownership they had to empower
each vertical team to deliver a feature
without this endless matrix of
dependencies and we had to build
expansible but still shared horizontal
infrastructure that everybody could use
so far we've seen how far duet Ai and
app sheet can get you when you want to
add new workflows to existing systems
but let's be real a lot of the things
you might be working on still involve a
lot more traditional Cloud building
blocks they're slinging containers your
tweak and release pipelines and we want
to build those platforms as efficiently
and reliably as possible please welcome
Google Cloud Champion innovator Lucas
Carlson I would say the three main
things that I'm always trying to improve
first how are applications respond to
scaling events how do we better handle
surges in traffic sure second we want to
make sure the infrastructure is easy to
maintain for our platform engineering
teams so they can spend more time doing
things that add value rather than just
keeping the lights on and finally we
always want to make sure that we can
build experiences that are more
personalized for our customers there's
actually another really cool feature
that came out of preview recently yeah
that you might want to experiment with
it's called CPU boost
all right CPU boost allocates more CPU
at startup time specifically to reduce
your cold start the initial experiment
proved that people like the app we'd fix
some of the scaling but now we want to
push it to more places from just one
region to maybe multiple this is where
Cloud deploy can come in it's one of my
favorite Services Cloud deploy also
recently added the ability to deploy to
multiple Targets in the single stage so
for example imagine deploying to three
different regions at the same time
that's super useful but what about some
functional improvements we got the easy
stuff but now let's actually kind of fix
some of the app we've noticed that it's
a retail app right so we have some
abandoned carts a little more than usual
and we want to poke those customers no
idea I don't know let's see if the
weather Ai and Cloud workstations can
help us write some code either the
comment just from that we can generate
all the code we need to talk to postgres
database to Loop through the rows and
then to email each customer that has an
abandoned card so let's take a step back
what we just did here in just a few
minutes we made our application more
performant with CPU boost
and instance configuration we use
parallel deploys to actually serve this
in more regions different users and then
we're really running fully managed Cloud
run jobs without writing a whole ton of
code that we have to maintain
turns out there was a zero day
vulnerability in a little open source
Java Library called log4j
let me without further Ado introduce you
to our next Champion innovator Mark
Johnson Mark coming up here
so you know we got to talk about
security got to talk about security so I
like to think about s3c in three pieces
number one how are we securing our
developer environments number two how
are we ensuring the Integrity of the
build process itself and then finally
how do we protect that app once it's
running in production so let's begin
where all good things begin in Cloud
workstations so let me just kick off the
build of this app here and it's running
and while that's running let's take a
look at a previous run actually that
succeeded so I've got Cloud build up
here and you can see I've got a couple
successful runs and when we take a look
at this notice we've got a bunch of
steps let me pull this out so you can
see it a little bit better that are
leading us down to something called
binary authorization so if I jump over
to Binary authorization here in the
console you'll see that not only do I
have the policy itself but next to it I
have something called a testers you say
what are a testers let me scroll out so
you can see those a little better a
testers I like to think of those kind of
like cryptographic Pokemon all right and
I'm going to collect those along the way
in order to earn that binary off check
mark at the end of my build process and
for those of you out there trying to be
systematic about how you put together a
software supply chain security flow like
this I do recommend you check out the
salsa levels at salsa.dev they can help
you identify how mature your security
checks are and what you may be missing I
know it's a lot of metadata on each step
but you do have your salsa build level
for you here and it's also important to
call out here that all these insights
are also available in new gke Enterprise
now you should see something super cool
which is our attack path simulation it
picked up a number of things for us
we've got a secure service account key
that's available from the public
internet I like these little red uh
exclamation points here because it
actually points to if we have other
related vulnerabilities there's kind of
this fractally integrated set of
problems in our account we can kind of
explore that in any direction it's like
Choose Your Own Adventure it's all
mapped out for us here in this nice
little attack path simulation and it
brings us all the way down to our demo
bucket which is where we have our build
blog stored so all that build metadata
we were creating before is actually
potentially exposed right now and this
is a good note that we need to fix it
I'll be honest I feel like my mind just
melted a little bit here one of my
long-standing forward-wishing look
looking uh just goals for cloud overall
to say hey AI just tell me which of
these containers have vulnerabilities
which policies are over permission and
just give me the steps to remediate them
don't make me guess don't make me put
together a bunch of tools
it really feels like we're starting to
get there
my name is and I'm an engineering
manager on the Google workspace team and
this spring my team wrapped up one of
the biggest data migrations in the
history of the planet and this is where
we ran into the spanicles
spatacles is a cute name we gave our
edge cases
basically these Barnacles hanging onto
the side of our spanner migration
and now we're ready to see how the world
of data is changing I'm excited about
this one to help us with that I'd like
to invite one of my friends on stage a
legendary Google Cloud Champion
innovator miles Ward we figured there
are three big opportunities that are
present first we have to simplify data
operations and that's got to include
security we've got to put all that data
to work be able to use it using the
power of AI and we want our cake and to
eat it too we want our choice of the
best open source tools and managed
services so we don't have to do so much
work so I did spin up we jumped to the
screen a typical data infrastructure
using the analytics lake house jumpstart
solution so to start off with first we
actually populate a bunch of those more
audio files in a cloud storage bucket so
to work with them I've gone ahead and
created a new object table in Big Lake
I'm such a huge fan of how this big
length model it simplifies the security
operations of working with data like
this so I've got a big query function
here
that goes ahead you can see next speech
to text function this is actually
transcribing the data from the audio
file and putting it in bigquery so let's
go ahead and invoke that so I want to
run this function so it's going to go
through everything in that object table
listen to the audio and then transcribe
it for us it's a bunch of audio
transcription so using this model look
where we got all of the audio from those
files now right there okay so let's see
if you can get it to find like a
specific type of safety incident like
maybe all the reports that say injury or
something right because I'm terrible at
writing SQL so when I can just give it a
comment and have it give me a query
statement that's uh that's making
everybody better let's see if we can
transform this data into something more
useful I want to get out one of the
bigquery studio notebooks for this
workload I get and I hope you are too so
excited about this combination of Open
Source and manage tooling like yep give
me spark is the execution engine if
that's what I want alongside bigquery as
the data repository or if I want to fine
tune an llm and pytorch you know Cloud
tpus now support that I mean I could
bring in data from Apache Iceberg now if
I want to here's where it gets fun look
under the hood bigquery studio notebooks
are built on top of colab Enterprise
this is the cloud ready version of
Google collab notebooks that many of you
have known and loved for years let's
actually invoke the Palm API so we can
summarize Maybe that lengthy summary
there and get back a nice little
description
that we can figure out which factories
are a hot mess
oh there we go I think you showed me the
little magic wand button if we come back
we see there's a summary I'm getting a
single sentence summary of what might be
a really long transcription right I'm
doing all this in the data frame again
I'm not leaving my tool set so everybody
take a minute to appreciate what just
happened we pulled in that vertex
integration no containers or extra side
cars we didn't stand up some giant model
or run it on a bespoke massive instance
in order to get it close to our data
it's it's just right there it's waiting
in the platform for us it's an API a
call away
when I started as a search engine
mechanic at this little startup called
Google
um it was natural to try and build it on
top of PCS because their price
performance was still unbeatable and so
when it came to copying a new web index
a new search index from one place to
other add to another it was really hard
to beat the bandwidth of a Honda full of
hard drives
what's in a legacy today we've seen that
the way we prototype our apps the way we
modernize our platforms secure our
workloads even the assumptions we have
about our data not choices that we have
to be trapped in in the past we can
challenge our assumptions even while we
celebrate what came before
foreign